Hey,
so this was the big issue that
Julie probably has ever had.
We had about 40 crew members
over 80 cast members.
Um,
and it was just absolutely insane.
I was insanely fun for all of the sand.
It was just such a humbling experience
to be able to work with such talented,
um, and amazing people. Um, honestly,
this film could not have been
possible without my amazing team.
This is a very deeply
personal story for me. Um,
and it's something that I care so
much about and I am so humbled and
appreciative of everyone who were able
to come together or we just feel really
fortunate because jubilee project came to,
I get the opportunity to have the stories
Alzheimer's disease told through their
wonderful work.
So our hope is that it'll continue to
raise awareness and raise involvement,
hit more people drawn to our services
and more people supporting the word.
Uh, my name's Jason Today.
I am the one eight D,
which means I'm the main person on set
and screams at everyone as how's or one
that they're late and behind schedule.
This is my angry face
when we're behind on time.
Hi, I'm Rachel. I am the, it's
been a good student so far.
Everybody has been super on top of
things and really, really well behaved,
very talented.
So it has been a very easy process to
work with everybody. You have a great,
fantastic, great crew, great parents, um,
people really willing to
open up locations for us.
And there's a good time,
Rachel,
first time producing a film,
but I had a great director to work easy.
Come on please.
They cast and crew there is,
she got so many compliments about how
organized this production was and like
people who've been on sets for really,
really long time.
Like Joe Joe said that this is really
organized of all the films I've worked on,
this was the most organized.
Wow.
I am Robert.
I am the gaffer.
I am doing pretty much all
of the lighting, setting
up all the lighting here.
And uh, it's a smaller crew.
So you said there's no grip.
So,
uh,
some kind of doing the grip department
and the electric department with Marshall
DP,
obviously
they are just evil.
No slave labor work 50 hours a day,
um,
as as well possible because you can see
by this kids they were all wiped out.
A very big thank you to yes
style.com for sponsoring.
Um, all this amazing clothing. Um,
you guys really came through.
I had so much fun going through your
site and you're picking out some awesome
pieces for our after Joe.
We really wanted him to look refined,
dapper and have a little bit of
personality in this club
performance has been unreal. Um,
both, uh, Joe and today I had just
really comes in body. Their character.
They're no longer actors.
They are Arthur and the melody.
So this is pretty much
my first acting sharp.
How do you like it?
I love it.
Do you like the character melody?
Yes.
What do you like about her?
She seems very nice and she cares a
lot for grandpa and I also always like,
like characters dance.
I started dancing
like training when I was seven years old,
but my mom put me in classes since
I was three. Makes me feel good,
especially better. Amber.
Maybe I had a bad day.
Sometimes I just,
I think everybody should dance because
it makes everybody feel better.
And it's a way to express your
emotions through movement and exercise.
What was it like working with surveyor?
We hit it off. We had a good
time. How many she was trying
to braid my hair today.
You saw, why did it make me
look like a Unicorn? But no,
she's great. She's a great little
actress and a great person.
She really is.
And I think it's important to show how
a child react in it showed her in a very
positive light helping your grandfather
and it showed a love between two
generations,
did it pretty far apart.
It can really work
if you love each other.
Oh sweet.
The worst part is when you feel like
you did it right and it says miss
also,
uh,
go back
to
go
box
right
now,
the crew and cast that we worked with
those your first phone.
Thank you.
You were so good
and
you're awesome
fun
and
really grateful for being a part of it.
So this story is inspired
by my grandfather.
My grandfather raised me when I was
just the baby because my parents
were, um, out of the country working.
And so I grew really close with them, but
he was diagnosed with Alzheimer's, uh,
several years ago and he got to a point
where he no longer even recognize me
anymore. Um, and so I didn't
really know how to respond.
I essentially just kind
of ran away from him,
even stopped caring for him until one day.
Um,
we're just sitting in the same room
and I hear him mumbling and I lean in
closer.
And what I heard was this
absolutely amazing story
that he was trying to tell me
about the time that he was fighting this
war and in 1940 [inaudible] and using,
being pushed down into the south end to
these caves and had nowhere else to turn.
And I was amazed. I was
stunned. I was like, wow,
this is my grandfather who,
you know,
can't even remember what he had
for dinner the night before,
but being able to share this really rich
and personal history that he had many
decades ago.
And that was really the turning point
in which I saw him as a different person
as my grandfather again.
And that taught me a lot about him,
um,
about someone with Alzheimer's,
even though they lost their memories,
they still have capacity to feel love and
their emotions outlast their memories.
Ultimately, the main takeaway for
this film is to live what you love.
For every one of us, um,
we have that passion.
We have that drive that
really makes us come alive.
And so that's why I believe that
ultimately this is a story about love. Um,
and it's important to live what you love,
um,
because that's what at the end of
the day truly helps us come alive.
And that's what melody and Arthur to
do for each other. What happens is
this, this dance scene is the last scene
of a film in which the granddaughter,
her name is melody, is on the stage
and she's dancing in the talent show,
but she ends up messing up
and she falls in the grounds.
And what happens is the Grandpa to
show her his support stands up in the
audience and search the stance.
And,
and slowly one by one different groups
of people will start joining him as this,
as a sign of solidarity
strap.